the first day of school in times of
coronavirus
these six-year-olds waited for more than
two months to start their education
the iraqi government lifted the lockdown
in september
but public schools only reopened this
week
it was supposed to start earlier but
they delayed it because of the large
number of infections
yes the malls and the shops reopened
earlier but the number of infections was
very high
now the numbers have started to go down
hopefully the pandemic will go away soon
and we will try to catch up on schooling
the pandemic has further widened
pre-existing disparities in education
private schools catering to wealthy
students have largely stuck to the
academic calendar
while public schools like these stopped
teaching for eight
months budget cuts due to declining oil
prices
have made matters worse
for sure there's been a negative effect
the pandemic has delayed school
attendance and in addition to that the
budget is basically zero
private schools have better health
measures than government schools
and also the number of students is
smaller they have better financial
capabilities
even though public schools are back in
session many parents will continue to
play a big part in their children's
education
students will attend class only one day
per week
and have to study at home on the
remaining school days
but compared to many other countries
iraq lacks a telecommunications
infrastructure
to support e-learning the education
ministry says it will launch
applications to facilitate online
classes
but while many wait for such plans to
materialize
ahmed and ayman both in their final year
of high school
say that's of little help they say there
will be online classes but it won't be
successful the internet is very bad we
cannot study like this our only choice
is to take private tutoring classes we
can't depend on the government schools
they already missed school during much
of last year when classes were cancelled
due to widespread anti-government
protests
now the pandemic risks shattering their
hopes for university
the good universities won't admit us
then we'll have to go to private college
and pay millions of iraqi dinners
we can't afford that iraq's financial
and health crises have cast
uncertainty over the country's future
but at least for now
this new generation of students are
enjoying a return to a routine
that resembles normal life simona
faulting al jazeera
baghdad